está esa radio creada internacional
bienvenidos a que nada en las américas
café una emisión producida por la
sección en español del difusor público
radio canadá internacional difundimos en
directo cada viernes a las dos y cuarto
por las redes sociales en internet en
esta emisión les presentamos los temas
destacados de la semana y compartimos
sus mensajes enviados por correo
electrónico este programa también se
encuentra disponible en nuestro sitio en
internet r6 net punto sea y si quieren
escribirnos pueden hacerlo a la
siguiente dirección electrónica a black
eres el net punto sea y nuestro correo
regular que raramente llegan cartas es
radio canadá internacional apartado
postal 6000 montreal canadá h3c 38 y hoy
les acompañan en los micrófonos
louis lo bordó leonora chapman de un
arroz y menos hola a todo y quienes
habla ruso valencia en la versión radio
de este programa disponible en nuestro
sitio en 96 puntos o sea les
presentaremos la música de artistas
canadienses como bobby
nacido en el bei y fallecido en el
montón en 2016 a los 73 años de ir
escucharemos la canción hits que tiger
graba de 1961 de la cantante
quebequense nacida en todas vivieras
polín suriana escucharemos la canción
mami graba de 1974 y también
escucharemos al dúo de música electro
funk que se llama chrome o con el tema
más hábil debería haber sido esos temas
en nuestra versión audio en nuestro
sitio en internet
heresi net punto o sea bien estamos ya
oficialmente en otoño entonces es el
tiempo todavía creo que es el tiempo es
el tiempo de la cosecha de manzanas
es el tiempo de los zapallos de manzanas
empezamos a ver en el mercado también
están sonando
igual yo me acuerdo de haber ido a
juntar perdón me julio periodo juntar
manzanas a mediados o fines de octubre
no yo ya hay una amiga mía que fue a
buscar manzanas y me trajo de regalos en
findes más iguales
tiempo de los abrigos con el tiempo de
la mañana
es el tiempo de la tos es el tiempo lo
re fríos la cantidad de gente resfriada
es increíble pues bueno sale como si
hiciera calor y hace frío entonces se
pone un abrigo transpira se saca se
enferma y así la rueda es positivo en
otoño
las manzanas son positivas ya nuestros
amigos oyentes que cada en casi muchas
regiones de canadá cada principio de
otoño se lleva se lleva a cabo esta
especie de ritual de las familias que
salen de la ciudad y van a recoger a
realmente a tomar de los árboles las
manzanas y les entregan uno llega al
lugar para un monto x que serán 12 o 20
dólares si sabes si a veces no pagas
nada y te dicen recoja las manzanas
antes que se pudran pero a veces tú
faltas o por aunque tengas que pagar
porque como haces y por a mí me pasó la
primera que fuera
una de estas granjas
era enorme había llevado mis bolsas que
eran enormes también y me puse a juntar
manzanas de dos árboles y cuando terminé
me fui como pancho por su casa nunca le
pagué nada a nadie nunca nadie me dijo
nada bueno a mí hace poco una amiga fue
a buscar manzanas y me dijo que no pagó
nada se fue a un lugar y recogió las
manzanas del suelo de los árboles ya
caídos entonces en ese caso me parece
que las que están caídas si las pueden
pagar pues estaban riquísimo creo que es
así pero las que las que yo corté corte
me acuerdo del arbolito
había dos manzanas colgando estaban
charlando una cerca de la de arriba es
el herria y la bajo la mira dice qué te
pasa inmadura
y entonces es uno de los rituales
también viene de halloween a fines del
próximo mes octubre
que también es la es la decadencia de
los zapallos y que también tengo una
anécdota con eso venga cuando cuando fui
la primera vez a una fiesta de esta de
halloween que fui acompañando la que en
aquel entonces era la pequeña hija de un
matrimonio amigo
yo salí con mi campera de media estación
traída de la argentina porque total
durante el día no había estado demasiado
frío que digamos la niña está que en ese
momento tenía 56 años mejoraba con su
vestido de princess y no sé qué y yo al
rato me empecé a ofrecer frío
porque la temperatura empezó a bajar
repentinamente y de los 20 y mientras
ella estaba contenta juntando golosinas
y que yo estaba congelando me
hay que abrigarse para halloween y
porque el decir que es la decadencia de
los zapatos porque porque si los botan
algo hay mucha gente que no lo votan en
mi casa por ejemplo si ponemos un sábado
afuera que lo decoran mis hijas si
después de terminado halloween la cosa
cuelga ya y así si yo no sé si todo el
mundo lo hace si el latino y uno como
también lo de veces más creo que hay más
gente y más gente que año tras año
reutilizar justamente para no despreciar
para los demás está caro el zapallo a lo
mejor no es grande del halloween pero a
éstos zapallitos que le decían coreanos
en argentina están caros y entonces me
imagino que uno no quiere tirar esos
zapatos tampoco claro bien entonces
entramos a esta parte breve parte de las
noticias sorprendentes porque dicen
coreanitos no tengo idea bueno
manolito que seguramente le puso supongo
que originalmente eran de allí así que
creo que en américa no no no los vinos
conozco los coreanos en bolivia una
migración coreana que llegó un momento
dado en los años
los 70 y 80s y tenían la
lo ideal es que vayan a la región del
oriente para cultivar arroz donde les
dieron tierras y creo que algún dinero
pero muy rápidamente los coreanos
acarrearon el dinero y se fueron a las
ciudades e instalar una serie de
mercados y importaban chamarras ropa
entonces se acabó los coreanos acabaron
siendo conocidos más que como
agricultores como comerciantes es muy a
precios muy abordables para el resto del
mundo igual que tiene no solamente hubo
inmigración coreana y china sino de la
época que vos decís en época de la
dictadura en argentina hubo inmigración
la océana de gente de laos que llevaron
en un supuesto gesto humanitario a la
argentina para que trabajara en el campo
los tiraron al campo y después de unos
días que fueron raudamente hacia buenos
aires y después de buenos aires- huyó
raudamente hacia laos de vuelta
océanos chinos y coreanos y por todo
y que destacan la semana de los trabajos
de lo más sorprendente obviamente está
pasando en este momento en los eeuu
donde se está sometiendo la decisión de
la del senado de los eeuu la situación
de uno de los postulantes o del
postulante del presidente de donald
trump a la corte suprema de justicia
algo que se estará decidiendo en escasa
hora más por cada una y media hora del
este está previsto el voto en el senado
de este postulante acusado ya por tres
mujeres de haber cometido actos
indecentes y que sin embargo sigue
siendo sostenido por el presidente de
donald trump como su postulante estrella
para asegurar la primacía conservadora
en la corte suprema de los estados
unidos creo que ese es el tema
excluyente
dentro de lo que es actualidad para mí
lo que me sorprende esta semana es decir
llamó mi atención también es la decisión
del parlamento canadiense de retirar la
ciudadanía a la líder birmana es este
aunque san suu kyi que knox y cuchi no
sé cómo se pronuncia si ganadora del
premio nobel en 1991 y canadá le había
otorgado la ciudadanía que es un cargo
muy honorífico y muy exclusivo se le dan
muy pocas personas en el mundo y esta
fue una moción presentada en el
parlamento esta semana presentada por el
partido bloque quebequense uno de los
tipos de los diputados federales y que
fue unánimemente votado a favor y
entonces estoy a ella se la acusa de
haber permanecido guardado el silencio
mientras el ejército birmano cometía
genocidio contra una población y roaming
a los rohingya musulmanas de ese lugar y
hay que decir que es canadá fue el
primer país en acusar de genocidio
contra esta minoría musulmana entonces
eso es un hecho sin precedentes de
canadá efectivamente y esa ciudadanía
honorífica la recibieron por ejemplo de
la nelson mandela y también el dalai
lama exacto y se le da muy pocas muy
pocas personas y esta es la primera vez
en la historia de canadá que se retira a
esa ciudad y hay un lugar creo que está
en el en el oeste canadiense donde están
reflejadas las imágenes en fotos de
estas personas que recibieron la
ciudadanía honorífica ida hace un año y
medio se había cómo sacar apagado la luz
de la foto la líder líder birmana en el
museo de derechos humanos que esto es
tan bueno que me parece que sí
y se había se le había bajado digamos la
intensidad de la luz como para pagarla
dentro de ese centro nación ni amos
entre comillas para remarcar bueno
justamente esto no fue una limpieza
étnica y esto lo dijo
el ex hombre de nuestro pobre ex
ministro de la provincia de ontario en
un momento dado y que ocupó grandes
puestos acá con cargos políticos con los
liberales pues el gobierno este liberal
lo envió en una misión de investigación
a birmania para investigar sobre este
esta matanza contra esta población
hoy que no es un campo de refugiados
sino un campo de concentración las
semanas y dos semanas con el programa
francés se habló con una mujer
canadiense que trabaja la cruz roja
trabajando ahí con él fueron y dice que
realmente es imposible como esa gente
sigue viviendo en esas condiciones y ese
es lo que dicen es realmente es una
limpieza étnica y es un genocidio
entonces eso fue para mí lo que a mí lo
que me atrajo la atención esta semana
que a mí lo que me llamó la atención es
así -ha 10 años no es nada eso es una
burla por favor la eso
legitimizar acaban
trump con todas las acusaciones que
tiene de cuestiones en conductas
sexuales y que a este hombre le de 3 a 5
no sé no sé me parece me parece visual
lo que pasa que además claro él tiene
hubo como 50 mujeres que lo acusaron a
crosby pero sale este juicio era sólo
una mujer pero incluso sabiendo lo que
pasó a mí me parece que tres años de sus
regalos y de tres a cinco igual
un año sí porque está ciego le van
igualmente las atrocidades que hizo las
hizo o sea y lo que destacó como dato
curioso en esta fecha vintage era el
furioso nosotros dijimos lo que nos
llamaba la atención
[Risas]
bueno en mi caso es curioso
lo que me llama la atención es que este
este viernes 28 de septiembre es el día
de la amistad con un vegetariano que
inventó esa hora pues está desde acá
desde afuera está en los archivos de la
bici de la radio pública canadiense que
lo anunciaron con 12 si están archivos
quiere decir que es algo antiguo no fue
archivo es algo que hace una hora
y si logras agasajar y bonos o
vegetariano que haces
ensalada de frutas manzana
es muy bueno de manzanas manzanas con
queso fundido y con neal con esos esas
nueces y con las nueces y si no se hace
una buena barbecue con los hongos estos
llamando con gran de portovelo tengo
hambre
recuerdo que están en sintonía de radio
canadá internacional y este programa se
llama que nada en las américas café y
vamos a dar ahora lectura a los a las
cartas y mensajes que hemos recibido de
vuestra parte louis si aquí tengo un
mensaje que nos envía
paloma gea sobre el tema avance
importante para mejorar la visión de
pacientes con glaucoma ella dice hola
desearía saber más sobre este nuevo
descubrimiento y qué se puede hacer o
dónde hay que ir para conseguir este
tratamiento me interesa muchísimo
gracias y saludos y como decimos
habitualmente la información está en el
material publicado y es para gente que
reside en el lugar donde este
tratamiento se está llevando a cabo no
es cierto
tengo un comentario sobre el tema en
méxico lópez obrador se niega a entrar
en el juego del muro con el presidente
trump escribe nuestro amigo mejicano
javier gonzález nungaray y dice este
señor trump y sus ideas de la época de
la edad media haciendo un poco de
historia el tema del muro de berlín se
construyó con una finalidad dividir a
alemania es decir cerrar el libre paso
de las personas y a fin de cuentas fue
derribado la migración no se va a acabar
construyendo muros y utilizando el poder
o la fuerza amigos drs y el cerrar la
frontera por medio de un muro de 5
metros de altura no acabará con la
migración del sur al norte se necesita
una justicia económica para todos los
pueblos es decir acabar con la pobreza
porque ustedes emigraron del sur de
américa para canadá es la pregunta que
nos hacen a carbono pregunta s puesta
para un programa de sí sobre vamos a
hablar entre tocas el programa en
siguiente lo hacemos entero hablando de
las motivaciones por las cuales uno vino
en realidad
e
mi hermano vino aquí después de la una
de las una de las crisis en argentina y
me dijo es un hermosísimo lugar para
hacer crecer a tus hijos y nosotros no
tenemos hijos con mi esposa y nos
venimos a probar suerte sin salir de
ningún justo coincidió con una crisis
pero nosotros no estábamos tan en crisis
en ese momento pero tenía trabajo mi
esposa también pero sin embargo hicimos
los trámites y decidimos venir a probar
la reunificación familiar
mi hermano se había venido en la época
de la crisis en el momento de alfonsín
y nosotros bueno a mí me duele la vista
dice el función del año 87 87 exacto no
pero en el 2001 me llegó la visa a mí
que es justo sacar una semana después de
la salida en helicóptero del presidente
les digo nosotros vamos a empezar los
trámites dos años antes o sea no fue por
eso que nos fuimos nosotros estábamos
justo en ese momento físicamente
emplazados ahí pero no tenía nada que
ver con nuestro proyecto de inmigración
y era para intentar una mejor mejor
pasar y darle más oportunidades a
nuestros hijos y estamos muy contentos
mágicamente eso bien entonces vamos a ir
revelando poco a poco la razón historia
y las historias oscuras ya descubra si
no es claro y largas porque son pues hay
mucha historia detrás de cada persona
sentada en esta limpieza fue
absolutamente resumido no podemos entrar
en pregunta porque eso es lo que son por
qué elegiste la profesión que elegiste
yo siempre creí que eso no se puede
contestar con una sola idea y un
conjunto de razones que lo llevan a uno
elegir la profesión que eligió si es que
en definitiva él eligió porque a veces
muchas veces uno cae en la cuenta de que
terminó adentrándose en algo sin haberlo
elegido del proceso pero yo creo que en
el caso de la de la inmigración no creo
que haya una sola
razón para emigrar debe haber un
conjunto de razones que involucran
cuestiones bastante bastante profunda no
creo que no hay haga las maletas y se
vaya de su país por un simple acto de
curiosidad ni mucho menos estamos
supuesto por supuesto mucho más
complejos que eso sí tienes razón a
veces encuentra la profesión pues en mi
caso estaba convencido de que en casa
abierta esta radio antigua se guarda
telefunken esas radios con las filiales
casi como de marfil y una luz medio
fosforescente entonces ésta tenía cinco
años estaba convencido que detrás de la
radio había enanitos que en la caja de
enanitos y obviamente daba la vuelta a
la radio para esperarlos aquí después
del programa
bien entonces aquí tengo un comentario
en este caso también sobre el tema para
en realidad también porque hace ya
muchos meses que nos llegan este tipo de
mensajes recuperando sonrisas son
programas dentistas canadienses para
mujeres marginales
fatma nos manda un mensaje es buenos
días me recomendaron buscar este sitio
para arreglarme la boca tengo 34 años
necesito sonreír trabajo cara al público
y no con una sonrisa los clientes me
comentan que estoy muy seria necesita
sonreír y bueno le decimos a fatma que
lo mismo que al resto de la gente nos
escribe si ella vive en toronto es
excelente porque ese programa no sé si
en realidad sigue vigente ahora pero
estuvo hasta hace muy poco vigente para
la gente en toronto y también
recomendamos en realidad hacer una
pequeña investigación por internet
porque suponemos que este tipo de
programas y hemos constatado que en
otros países se realiza así que debe
haber un montón de ciudades de distintos
países programas similares bien
recordamos que en nuestra versión en
radio en por enero en punto sea
escucharemos artistas como bobby cartola
también
pollin xulián y también el grupo premium
y quizá también coloquemos a leonard
cohen en nuestra nuestra y policial ya
no la pones justamente porque hay una
película películas sobre ella en este
momento y yo me acuerdo muy bien de paul
influyan cuando yo llegué era era poli y
julián era en su gran época de cantante
no y además estaba me acuerdo era una
militante pues de los derechos de las
mujeres una feminista de primera línea
además un artista y creo que estaba
también casada o era compañera de un
diputado que en aquel entonces un
diputado quebequense que el entonces sí
señor gerardo de que además ella era
algo de tenía una actitud muy abierta
hacia en ese momento los refugiados que
venían de chile y de argentina me
acuerdo perfectamente de él entonces era
era una pareja muy muy presente en la
realidad quebequense y ella pues es una
en el oeste de la isla de montreal cerca
donde yo vivo hay un ser que se llama
gerald golden y la sala
de presentaciones artísticas se llama
paul y willy
para mí son gente yo identifico a canadá
los primeros recuerdos son ellos también
claro y quienes viste montreal cuando
vayan salgan por ejemplo del metro muy
guay al salen del metro y miran el muro
que está detrás de la estación del metro
y está un texto desde algo tan quien
también a un poeta faith a un gran poeta
también a poeta que se pasaba por la
avenida del parque es una calle donde se
instaló mucha inmigración griega y lo
que fuera fue cura antes fue si no me
equivoco era cura dejó los hábitos si no
me equivoco el trabajo de la nada
trabajo en radio
nacional genere trabajo si en realizaba
internacional también entonces hay mucha
gente que pasó justamente molesta por
esta institución
entonces si efectivamente en una
película un documental por instruyan
íntima a su sobrina o su única la que lo
hizo creo que eso no lo sé más un
pariente es unos jóvenes y entonces y
esto cabe justamente momentos en que
quebec pues él en pocos días más
habrán elecciones provinciales y vamos a
saber que de una forma va a dar un
indicio también el termómetro de cuál es
el fervor independentista de esta
provincia que está de capa caída porque
los tiempos han cambiado muchísimo aquí
tengo saludos de gente que nos está
escuchando bien también está toda la
gente que está con nosotros
vía youtube vía facebook o en nuestro
sitio
tenemos por ejemplo bueno nuestra colega
paloma martínez dice hola colegas un
saludo grande pablo gómez barrios otro
también la marcha escucha viendo dice
hola a todos yo vine a canadá por amor
dice pablo contando cuando efectivamente
el porqué de su llegada a este país
llegue rotundamente enamorado de una
canadiense que conocía en la paz eso fue
allá en el año 1975 hace un poco más de
43 años también tenemos otro mensaje de
javier gonzález nungaray que dice amigos
de recibir programa para las américas
café un saludo cordial para todos y un
gusto tremendo escucharlos diría pablo
escucha verlos como dice mañana y susana
ochoa
los championes con un bar o los guau no
nos llega en que en referencia a los
vinos debe ser porque vino amigo pero no
sé si ahora sí exacto champiñones con un
bar o lo es
ya que estamos con mensajes para acá no
dar las américas café tengo uno que nos
dejaron también en nuestro sitio y es de
eduardo gutiérrez y dice hola buenas
tardes les saludó a todos útiles de la
provincia the class la escala franca la
atrás atrás cala tlaxcala tlaxcala ok
méxico sólo dice para felicitar a todo
el equipo de café en las américas y
comentar que hacen buenos comentarios
me gustaría que trataran más temas de
salud y un abrazo a su equipo como a
toda la audiencia por este medio muchas
gracias
antes de por toda la gente de gente que
me preguntaba por los medios sociales
que había pasado con el premio d
los latin awards canadá 2018
lamentablemente en nuestra categoría no
ganamos pero ya voy a tener la lista de
todos los ganadores para contarle a la
gente por qué no
consecutivo
no porque no me enteré este año que las
nominaciones uno puede autonominarse o
presentar digamos el medio para el que
trabaja para que pase a consideración
para ver si es nominado o no en alguna
de las categorías nosotros no nominó a
alguien que no fuimos nosotros o sea es
un gesto que parece más de objetivo
claro exacto y me parece ético es más
ético y al mismo tiempo quiere decir que
hay gente que nos aprecia mucho y que
nos ponen para eso así que si se mueve
al ida bueno para avisarle a la gente
que no ganamos pero si ganamos
habría que ver entonces quiénes serán
los finalistas y vaya la información
justamente el mensaje de participable
entonces el resumen sería que la gente
viene a que nada
no toda la gente pero bueno una parte la
gente viene por dos razones o por balas
o por besos o por razones económicas
ruffa hay más que eso hay más razones sí
pero una de las razones es el amor de
eso estoy segura yo estoy segura que
incluso debe haber mucho de eso
efectivamente bien pasamos arriba el
amor no claro aunque sean otoño además
fue aquí montreal que se hizo es evelyn
de john lennon y yoko ono diciendo bueno
hay que ser al amor y no la guerra
aumentos de la guerra de vietnam bien
entonces pasamos ahora rápidamente al
sector en el cual nosotros les
recomendamos que escuchar en nuestro
sitio en internet eres en el punto sea y
louis tú hablas de joyas zinc en un tema
que estoy de hecho trabajando todavía no
lo terminé por eso no lo tenía preparado
para que incluso leo pueda mostrar
imágenes pero la semana próxima se
inaugura en montreal exactamente el 3 de
octubre la primera exposición de los
argentinos en esta ciudad es una
exposición que se realiza a partir de
una iniciativa de
una galería de arte del consulado
argentino de otras entidades está
entrevistada en el material que yo hice
o que estoy preparando aún ana catalina
montoya que es la curadora hoyer al
mismo tiempo procuradora de esta
exhibición que es un viaje a la
argentina tiempo atrás para elegir a los
artistas a los orfebres y a los
materiales que van a ser expuestos y a
mí lo que me llamó la atención es que en
algún momento de la entrevista me
comienza a hablar de joyas hechas en
madera de plástico reciclado cuero y
tejidos y me pregunta obviamente fue qué
tiene que ver esto con la joyería y
según ella me explico es la nueva
tendencia de la joyería contemporánea
que surgió en argentina hablábamos un
poco de refilón de ese tema son rato
precisamente reyes de la crisis
económica que se vivió en el año 2001
cuando se salió de la paridad 11 peso
dólar y el país se fue a donde estuvo ya
tantas veces que es en la hecatombe
total en el tiempo de la relación carnal
con eeuu las relaciones carnales habían
terminado ahora venía lo peor ahora
el presidente argentino que está
enamorado
y que espera que los argentinos
también de la directora internacional
exactamente eso
ah caramba cuestión de gustos no
compartidos en todo caso no pero bueno
el tema es que esa crisis hizo que los
joyeros se vieran impedidos de comprar
los materiales que usan habitualmente
que son los materiales preciosos el oro
la plata etcétera porque el costo era
sideral con el tema de la salida de la
variedad dólar/peso los construcción
aumentaron terriblemente y tuvieron que
agudizar el ingenio como decíamos
temprano con leonora grial hicimos que
nos volvemos en tiempos de crisis pero
el dicho desde que las crisis son
ocasión de cambio es cierto que bueno
aquí lo demostraron tuvieron que
ingeniárselas para comprar para adquirir
para utilizar nuevos materiales en el
tema de la joyería y entre ellos estos
que yo nombré que en este momento no
solamente son utilizados por
los argentinos sino que se están
convirtiendo en una de las tendencias
preponderantes en la joyería
contemporánea eso se podrá ver a partir
del miércoles 3 de octubre aquí en
montreal y está en bastar en la nota la
dirección exacta de la galería de arte
en la cual será realizada la exposición
jan ahora tú nos hablas del rol de los
homosexuales en la evolución de las
familias el rol de los hombres
homosexuales porque le pregunté si a las
mujeres también y esa fue otra respuesta
es un investigador canadiense él se
llama francisco gómez jiménez es
investigador de comportamiento sexual
humano de la universidad del late bridge
en la provincia de alberta es un
especialista en el tema de la diversidad
sexual y él tiene en su investigación
que está llevando a cabo junto con otro
profesor de esta universidad él tiene su
hipótesis y que logró aprobarla y ahora
está trabajando a otro nivel y su
hipótesis es que los hombres
homosexuales mejoran la supervivencia de
sus familias esto es una evolución
aunque se viene dando en el tiempo y él
dice en entrevista si consideramos un
entorno ancestral porque ellos se
analizan en poblaciones ancestrales
por ejemplo cuando tener hijos era muy
arriesgado era cuando un ano en épocas
anteriores tenían hijos pues la mitad no
sobrevivía o más la mitad entonces
cuando tener hijos era arriesgado
especialmente tener muchos niños tener
un par de manos adicionales
definitivamente era útil es lo que él
dice y explica como
el homosexual el hombre en esta en este
tipo de familias al no tener hijos los
homosexuales es como que adoptan a sus
sobrinos sobrinas y están ayudando a
criar a esos niños lo que hace que estas
familias incluso tengan más hijos y de
esa manera como ellos no tienen hijos
hay más posibilidades que se reproduzcan
y que haya más niños pues homosexuales
también al tener más hijos entonces es
una investigación bastante larga que él
hizo él tiene un profesor profesor que
supo la base de la misma universidad que
anteriormente explica llevó a cabo una
investigación en samoa que es un país de
la polinesia donde la cultura de ellos
reconoce un tercer un tercer género
llamado fafa fin de no a los fast index
ya él se les asigna un género masculino
al nacer pero se sienten atraídos tanto
por hombres y exhiben rasgos masculinos
y femeninos
esto es fácil
es esta población lo que hizo y garcía
jiménez es el ir a méxico y estudiar y
está haciendo esa investigación con la
cultura istmo zapoteca que es en el sur
de méxico en oaxaca donde también hay
estos hombres parecidos a los de
polinesia asumen más o menos los mismos
roles y él está haciendo investigando en
méxico iba a publicar pronto esta
investigación sobre el justamente lo que
él llama el rol evolutivo de los
homosexuales hombres y lo interesante
también de la trayectoria de francisco
gómez jiménez es que tiene ganó un
premio es una subvención de la geografía
nacional la sociedad geografía nacional
que está muy interesada en esta
investigación y en publicar además de
los resultados las fotografías que le
está tomando de esta población del istmo
zapoteca en oaxaca si justamente hay un
pueblo hay un pueblo que es de donde él
está en mayor número de homosexuales
y justamente si en estas culturas
ancestrales estamos hablando de tiempos
de miles de años tal vez donde la
homosexualidad era una cosa natural es
decir el celular era una cosa aceptada
como en los animales no entonces no era
reprimido ni había ni se los perseguía
en las sociedades occidentales y estos
dos profesores hacen bien la diferencia
entre las sociedades occidentales y las
sociedades ancestrales entonces ese
cambio que se puede ver que es una
represión todavía muy grande en muchos
países en aquellas civilizaciones no
tenían nada que ver con lo que sucede
hoy en nuestros países lo loco es que
esa condena tan tan
autoritaria es tan fuerte con respecto a
los homosexuales en en países donde la
raíz indígena es muy grande es mayor
claro se mezclaba es increíble la
condena social para con el homosexual es
brutal
la comparación de en otros países donde
no se viven no se vivieron es muy grande
en méxico lo que ha cambiado un poquito
de tema pero en la misma línea lo que a
mí me sorprendió la vez pasada es leer
que la fifa estaba penalizando los
partidos en méxico porque los mexicanos
los que van a las canchas se ponen a
gritarle a los a los jugadores con
términos que no quiero repetir aquí pero
que tiene que ver muy fuerte ya en rusia
que ha pasado que lo que le pusieron una
multa no lo dejan entrar el sinn de
partidos se siguen gritándole lo que le
gritan a los arqueros cuando patean así
que en todo caso entonces esta es la
pareció interesante está esta entrevista
porque es la primera vez que uno sale
del esquema de decir simplemente bueno
hay homosexuales en todas las sociedades
tensiones eso está aprobado pero acá hay
como que hay una evolución y eso es lo
que me parece interesante de esta
investigación de inclusión en
canadienses dentro de las tradiciones
indígenas a cada vista de los indígenas
está también se tercer género si se le
puede llamar así y es el espíritu
el ser humano y espiritual en las
sociedades y nuit eso insiste desde hace
siglos es tan claro el vía espiritual
que se encargaba por ejemplo de las
decoraciones de las tiendas de las de
los titís y también justamente de de
hacer como de cuidados niños porque hay
que tomar en cuenta que es la el digamos
la expectativa de vida no era tan grande
sigue así' exactamente eso y no había
abuelas no había huevo había pocas pero
entonces el que haya una persona como
dice él un par de manos ayudando esta
era una ayuda pero increíble para esas
familias que también lo existe es decir
tener un tío una tía que te ayude a
crear tus hijos pues agradeces no por
supuesto
antes quería leer dos o tres mensajes
pablo que fue cura
de inmigración gracias paloma martínez
dice susan 8 es la maravillosa cata de
vinos
por eso menciona álvaro lo en el mix y
le dicen a la combinación un hombre que
tiene el maridaje en medidas con el
barolo y el esposo el barolo suena a
vino tinto a vino claro si manolo
extinto si no me equivoco y el hongo
para comer porque mi esposa es bueno
porque es nuestro lenguaje super
machistas esposas esto y esto el
maridaje marido y esposa bien
leonardo no sabrás plantear una pregunta
interesante implantaría un localizador
subcutáneo para cuidar a sus hijos y una
pregunta para terminar
en realidad hay una empresa en eeuu que
está empezando a ofrecer el servicio y
de eso se trata justamente la historia
es por dónde hasta donde cuidamos a los
niños hasta dónde podemos ejercer ese
control hasta donde es una cuestión de
libertades
y qué hacemos para cuidarlos y
pondríamos en un maratón adentro del
cuerpo de esa criatura para quedar la
fin de la civilización yo igual hay un
montón de cosas puntualmente con
respecto a la tecnología que con este
tipo de porque tiene que ser muy
pequeñito para estar puesto dentro de la
piel y funciona con un teléfono celular
por ejemplo esta tecnología que de la
cual hablamos en ese caso no es
infalible o sea si viene a alguien y
rapt a mi hijo y tire el teléfono ya
está digamos no tengo manera de
localizarlo porque ese tipo de es la
misma tecnología que se usa para el pago
con el teléfono que una cerca o la carta
que uno acerca la cara al lector al
lector si yo le pondría a mi hijo eso
pero si él me autoriza y si autoriza a
partir de los 16 años porque antes de
eso un niño que puede decir y estás al
mismo tiempo violando la intimidad de
ese link absolutamente bueno pero en
eliminación de la de de esta tecnología
no es tan invasiva porque en realidad el
niño tiene que hacer una acción para ser
localizada
esto voy a decir es decir acercar la
mano al teléfono para que el teléfono
reconozca que no está ahí es el teléfono
el que envía la posición de la criatura
por eso digo que en el caso de un rapto
si uno tiene el teléfono de hasta porque
no puede ss implante activarse solo como
es miniatura no tiene ni gps ni digamos
localizador global ni ningún tipo de
dispositivo ni batería eso es solamente
un chip que es leído por un teléfono
como entonces es solamente el gesto del
niño sobre el teléfono para avisar que
está en condiciones lo que pasa es que
se pierde teléfono es complicado
igualmente el artículo plantea la
posibilidad de llevarlo no sólo los
niños sino los adultos porque eso
generaría una especie de mejora en un
montón de cuestiones que tienen que ver
con nuestra vida por ejemplo nosotros
cuando unimos a radio canadá a trabajar
tenemos que entrar con una tarjeta
tenemos que llegar a nuestro puesto de
trabajo y loguearnos en la computadora y
abrirlo si colocas eso en tu mano en tu
dedo en donde fuera sabes el control que
van a tener sobre esa vida
es la contrapartida diego totalmente yo
creo que media lo que eso generaría no
por sobre todas las cosas es un ingreso
a quienes van a fabricar esos chiles
esfuerzos porque vamos a poner decir que
eres un ejemplo mucho más sencillo que
es el de la aplicación de esos chips que
se lleva a cabo desde hace mucho tiempo
en los animales mi perro tiene un chip
de esos puestos no hace ya algunos años
que supuestamente iba a facilitar un
montón de tareas que tienen que ver con
la identificación la historia médica o
veterinaria del animal etcétera y desde
que lo tiene hasta hoy en día la verdad
que ese chip se ha servido para nada
absolutamente para nada y el ejemplo en
real sirve a su auto día 4 la vacunación
cuando hablamos de implantar un chip en
un niño supongo que será el mismo
procedimiento que con un animal es un
chip tan tan tan pequeño que lo que se
hace en red además que implantar se
inyecta es con una sillería jackson que
se hace supuestamente van a la parte de
ss en la mano digamos para que no tenga
el acceso a la vamos a poder
confrontarlo con el teléfono para poder
enviar la señal
me recuerda justamente el hace pocos
días secuestraron a una niña de 12 años
a quien no entre al entonces por ahora
justamente para pedir un dinero a cambio
en la película con denzel washington en
que él justamente está trabaja de
guardián para una familia para una niña
en méxico sí señor entonces me pregunto
si hubiera tenido una niña ese ese
detector quizá no habría habido la
película porque donde películas de
secuestros también o sea sicario la
última película así que adiós pero dos
de esas extraordinarias de bill nighy sí
sí es extraordinaria y también ese se
encuentra en por túnel por debajo hacia
méxico manuel contaba justamente que con
el tema de la inmigración ilegal en eeuu
puedes construir un muro de 35
kilómetros hacia arriba na seguir
pasando así que pero es extraordinaria
esa película bien entonces ya que hablas
justamente del último recado de leonard
cohen y justamente una librería aquí en
montreal hace algunos días atrás se
organizó una lectura del libro post
el poeta monte titulado the flame la
llama y este lo que fue interesante es
que este libro fue presentado por cuatro
boxes jóvenes
alex nan lee así obscura doménica
martinello y natalia género este joven
álex mal y al empezar su presentación de
la lectura de ese libro decía muy con
mucha satisfacción que lo que él tenía
en común con leonard cohen es que él
había ido a la misma escuela maternal
cincuenta años más tarde y finalmente
cuando uno va a este tipo de eventos se
ve en el promedio de edad en quebec en
canadá es de 40 años o sea que ese tipo
de eventos por lo general se ven más
bien cabezas grises y aquí había jóvenes
pero aquí era sorprendente ver que todos
eran jóvenes y cómo los jóvenes se
apropian de esta voz desde este poeta y
pude conversar con una autora mexicano
canadiense ashleigh oscura quien
justamente ella explicaba que para para
ella este libro era justamente un regalo
póstumo de leonard cohen y que
justamente les permitía sobre todo a
quiénes
en raíces en otras partes de la red 6 de
enraizarse o de de acordarse que están
en montreal y tienen ese vínculo como
ante 'la como tú decías leonora como tú
muestra vas a leonardo en esta imagen de
leonard cohen pinta de un gran mural en
la ciudad y que con el tiempo pues se
está convirtiendo en la ciudad de
leonard cohen y jóvenes que viene de
otras partes de canadá van a encontrar
justamente en los textos de este poeta
montar en sí el nexo o el eslabón que
les va a hacer sentir en casa entonces
digamos que ese fue el tema entonces
después y hablando de leonard cohen
justamente hoy estaba leyendo que su
hijo adam cohen va a lanzar un disco
inédito de canciones inéditas nunca
antes que salieron al aire de leonard
cohen entonces pues habrá otro disco
sigue vivo
y quienes visiten montreal también hay
una aplicación que se llama paseos
urbanos y hay una aplicación que te guía
por las calles la ciudad diciendo te
explicamos de la vida
es como hacer un turno con la voz de
esta gran cantante martha wainwright
quien justamente pone la voz a esa
aplicación que cuyo ere y cuya sobrino
no hermano
que este flujo y rufus triunfos tuvo una
hija con la hija de la narco en sí sí ay
mira vos como uno va haciendo las
conectores la hija del disco en se llama
lorca
porque lo joven admiraba a este gran
escritor garcía lorca y desde aquí fue
gracias a él que finalmente descubrió
también escribir y pues sí tocar la
guitarra guitarra española exactamente
si bien ese es una inteligente historia
aquí llegamos al final del programa nos
quedan 10 segundos estuvieron hoy con
ustedes luis a bordo leonard a chapman 1
minuto 10 segundos entonces tenemos más
tiempo entonces podemos saludar los
espías quizá si se les pide a toda la
gente que se comunicó con nosotros y que
participó también sobre saludos en
nuestras redes sociales en este caso
pablo nos
de burra con el tema del vino y dice el
tinto del que hablaba susana es un tinto
italiano el valor la muestra yo pensé
que era
italia cosas
así que si el barolo italiano es era el
vino que nos recomendaban para el
portovello bien entonces eso es todo por
esta ocasión un abrazo a todos ustedes
cuídense mucho y estaremos de regreso en
siete días adiós